President Trump does have a nuclear
button on his desk but it is just for
Steve Bannon and I have many many
thoughts on this many a thought plus
Oregonians apparently don't know how to
pump gas which is a weird thing I didn't
know but we'll talk about all of these
things so many emotions so many things
to talk about I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
Steve Maddens the worst person ever hey
let's just start with that Steve is just
a garbage human being so to watch the
President of the United States turn his
wrath towards Steve Bannon is very much
akin to the scene in the new Star Wars
film spoiler alert
in the throne room with kylo Ren with
the lightsaber okay so it's a lot of
things happen yesterday and many of them
are good I think very good for the
administration actually the short term
effect is everybody's gonna say oh it's
chaos in the White House
guess what everyone's always saying that
crap but the question is whether it's
good for the administration short and
long term and the answer is the
disembowelment of Steve Bannon and
strewing the the plains with his
intestines was I think in the end a
quite good move for the administration
I'll explain why in just a second we'll
go through all the details all of the
gory details why this has happened
what's going on no one knows except for
me so we'll talk about it in just a
second but first I wanna say thank you
to our sponsors over at nature box so if
you're watching the news and you feel
like a snack as I so often do these days
the nature box is the place to go
so nature box will bring you all of the
most healthy snacks all of the most
tasteful snacks everybody in the office
loves nature box they have over 100
delicious snacks all snacks are made
with high-quality simple ingredients no
artificial colors flavors or sweeteners
it is easy just go to nature box comuter
snacks nature box delivers them right to
your door new snacks are added every
single month inspired by new food trends
and professional chefs and then customer
feedback and if you don't like a snack
the nature box will just replace it for
free which is awesome some of the ones
that are popular around the office the
vanilla bean wafers the coffee kettle
popcorn it's all great stuff everyone
around here would be getting fat except
for the fact that these snacks are a lot
healthier than the alternatives so
that's when naturebox.com/tyler men and
you get 50% off your first order
when you go to nature box calm down that
is nature box common it's perfect
for days like yesterday when you're just
sitting there I need a box of something
to just pop in your mouth as you watch
Twitter flash by nature box combat
efficiency of the news cycle it's just
fantastic
picture box that comes /ban 50% off your
first order alright so here we are again
now you may sense a bit of personal
satisfaction from yours truly
that's Steve Ben and
just got cut in half by the President of
the United States you would not be
mistaken Stephen is a bad man I've been
saying for well over a year the CPM is a
bad man I said in March 2016 the Steve
bandit had betrayed Andrew Breitbart so
legacy and then he had sold out
Breitbart to become his personal
political vehicle so I was first on this
boat and I don't mean like one of the
first I mean the first okay I was the
guy who was saying this for over a year
I said for two years that he was a
self-aggrandizing con man who leached
himself to more powerful players in
order to maintain power right this is
stuff that I was saying okay and I was
eminently correct and the president now
agrees I'm glad that the President of
the United States has come to the truest
most proper conclusion he has ever come
to in history ever okay he said the
truest things that have ever been said
about Steve Vienna so here is the the
lead up so the lead up is that Steve is
constantly leaking to the media for his
own self-aggrandizement I've been saying
this to members of the media look at
every interview that I've done over the
last year I've been saying Steve ban and
does not have any actual power he just
had the perception of power that
perception of power was being driven by
a rabid media interested in painting
President Trump as a rube and a hick who
didn't know what he was doing and
therefore Bannon was the power behind
the throne manipulating things like some
great puppeteer it was all nonsense
Bannon was never a great puppeteer
Bannon was always a guy who plastered
his lips to the ass of the most powerful
person that he could find and glued them
there like a barnacle until he could
ride them to glory and then when the
whale died then he like a like a virus
would find a new host and the parasite
would move on and he did this to Sarah
Palin he did the stander Breitbart
literally died not because abandon but
then he took over Benny he took over
Breitbart shop and turned into Bannon
calm look went were they were selling
Bannon fidgets spinners like five months
ago
hey we were trying to get some yesterday
here at the office but unfortunately
they are all out of stock in any case
Steve Bannon has been doing this as a
career move for a very long time and he
had cultivated a lot of people like he
had cultivated some of the hosts at Fox
News he'd become close with people like
Sean Hannity he he tried to paint
himself as the intellectual veneer of
trumpism and then he started to buy his
own press and this is always the fatal
flaw in this particular Greek tragedy
Steve Danon was the guy who was the
gimlet-eyed steel isolde fellow who was
going to maneuver his way to the top is
gonna be like How to Succeed in Business
Without
trying except without Robert Morris's
charm and he was going to simply ride
that wave all the way to power the
problem is he began to believe his own
press he began to believe that he was
the philosopher right he was the brain
of the Trump administration Trump was
the balls in the heart and Steve Bannon
was the brain he was the guy who was
really driving all of the activity and
he tried to make the media believe in
this right he would he would go into the
White House and he would have his
whiteboard behind him with all of the
promises I'm the guy who sits here for
20 hours a day trying to get things done
within three months he'd been
marginalized like very quickly he'd been
marginalized so he put himself basically
on the cover of Time magazine and that
was step number one and Steve started to
believe because he would go to these
rallies and people would cheer for him
because they saw him as a proxy for
Trump instead he started to believe that
people actually cared about Steve Bannon
no one ever cared about Steve Bannon
right people cared about Sarah Palin she
built herself a movement people cared
about Andrew Breitbart who is a
legitimately good human being whose
legacy has been betrayed and spit upon
by a subversive disgusting con man yeah
I knew Andrew I was close to Andrews
friends with Andrew for virtually all of
my adult life I mean literally I met him
when I was 17 years old and I worked
closely with him until his death his
Steve Bannon took his legacy and pissed
all over it for Steve bannon's own
personal aggrandizement there these are
people who actually built something
Steve Bannon has never built a damn
thing in his entire life he did not
build the Trump campaign he was not even
part of the Trump campaign except for
Mercer money the reason that Steve
Bannon was on the campaign is because
the Mercer's went to Donald Trump and
they said we want to put money into your
campaign why don't you take a couple
people were close with Steve Bannon and
Kellyanne Conway that's how they both
got on the Trump campaign this is
obvious and publicly available
information
hey Bannon was not the great manipulator
he was not the great genius he has a
good gift for getting in good with
people right this is what he does what
he does he goes to more powerful people
and he says I can make you even more
powerful just follow you be you let
Trump be Trump let Palin be Palin let
Breitbart be Breitbart this was his
shtick but then something happened to
Steve that's a good stick it's a good
stick as far as it goes but then I think
something happened to Steve and what
happened to see the Steve began to buy
his own press never buy your own press
particularly when the press is being
created by the leaks that you are person
applying to the press so Steve began
with this wishful thinking that he was
this very powerful player he would go to
the press he would leak all this
information to the press making him seem
like a powerful player and then he'd
start to believe what he
in the press that he leaked to the press
that he was a very powerful player and
this made him think I am the new face of
Trump ISM right I'm not that there is
Trump and then there's trumpism trumpism
is nationalist populism it's this grand
philosophy of a government that is going
to stand up for blue-collar working
Americans through tariffs and
infrastructure plans and higher taxes on
the rich it'll be a merger between
Bernie Sanders is domestic policy with
regards to taxing the rich for the
benefit of the Rust Belt workers and
it'll be a combination of that with pat
buchanan esque isolationism on foreign
policy in some areas where does this
kind of hard-nosed realism okay now that
was that was bannon's taken Bannen
thought that he could do it banned and
thought that he was going to take Trump
is him away from Trump and once you
start thinking that you are going to
take the movement away from the man you
are done because there is no trumpets
movement outside of Trump there isn't
okay people voted for Trump because they
liked the attitude they didn't vote for
Trump because he had a list of policy
proposals if people had voted for a list
of policy proposals MIT Romney would be
president right now people don't vote
for a list of policy proposals they vote
for people people voted for Trump they
voted for it from not because of his
policy I know Ann Coulter has this stick
today where she's saying people voted
for him because they wanted the
immigration reform it's true that if he
had run on a different platform on
immigration he might have gotten a
different voter base but to suggest that
if Donald Trump moved to the left on
immigration his entire base would desert
him that they are all ideologically
driven is just not the case it's just
not the case people voted for Trump for
two reasons he wasn't Hillary Clinton
and he had this this kind of this feel
of aggression right and people wanted
the feel of aggression it was much more
about Trump than it was about any sort
of cohesive political philosophy so
Steve tried to build a false cohesive
political philosophy around Trump but
even Steve didn't believe that see this
is the thing Steve didn't even believe
that what Steve believed is that he was
powerful enough to dupe people into
believing that he had a political
philosophy and then he was building a
movement around that Steve is dishonest
okay Steve is not interested in a
political philosophy any kind I talked
to him on the phone for two hours a day
for two years I know Steve pretty well
okay I know Steve better than believe
that Steve has a set notion of his own
political philosophy and every time the
media would ask me about this for four
years I would say he doesn't have one
and he's doing this for convenience he
thought how do i distinguish myself in
the marketplace well if I'm a typical
conservative then I'm no different than
Mitch McConnell or then Paul Ryan more
than a bevy of other conservatives who
put
conservatism so what can I do well Trump
is different and his policy proposals
are different and all over the place
what if I craft a new philosophy and I
make myself the avatar of that new
philosophy and then Trump is superfluous
to that philosophy because people voted
for the philosophy then in vote for
Trump and I'm a better face for that
philosophy than Trump is I'm smarter
than Trump probably true I am more I'm
more ballsy than Trump probably not true
I'm more correct charismatic than Trump
obviously not true he looks like a
homeless refugee from the Vietnam War
right the idea that Steve Bannon was
ever going to capture the trumpet's
movement and move it away from Trump is
just asinine it was never going to
happen but he began to buy his own press
and that's why Steve after he was ousted
from the administration had become
completely marginal he had no impact on
the administration none okay because he
had no impact on the administration he
had to come up with a new plan after he
left Breitbart I mean after he left the
Trump administration so he went back to
Breitbart which was the only place that
would have him he wasn't gonna get hired
anyplace else already been marginalized
already he goes back to Breitbart and he
comes up with a new plan and in just one
second I'm gonna explain to you Steve
bannon's new plan and how it
dramatically backfired and destroyed him
I'm gonna explain that in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at policy genius so from
policy genius is for people who are
interested in buying life insurance you
don't spend a lot of time thinking about
what happens if you die right cuz it's
dark and it's gloomy but perhaps you
should because it can happen at any
moment like now or now or now right you
could be dead listening to the rest of
the sad but here is the problem if you
haven't actually made those plans I'm
joking obviously I assume you're still
alive listening otherwise that's sad but
if you're still alive listen and go get
a life insurance policy because honestly
your family needs to be taken care of if
something bad should happen to you
people don't think about this until it's
too late and then it really is too late
because we don't have the capacity to
bring you back to life and buy a life
insurance so please go to policy genius
calm it's the easy way to compare and
buy life insurance online they let you
compare quotes in just five minutes it's
almost unheard of to make a responsible
purchase in five minutes the policy
genius can make you it can do this for
you and they don't just ensure life by
the way they insure everything you can
do health insurance disability insurance
pet insurance renter's insurance they've
helped over 4 million people shop for
insurance and they've placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage it basic
allows you to shop around and compare
and make all the best deals and get
exactly the program that is tailored to
you so if you made a New Year's
resolution to be better with money go to
policy genius.com easy way to compare
buy life insurance again knows no sales
pressure no no hassle and it is free
which means it's fiscally responsible
policy genius.com
get your new year's resolution resolves
in just five minutes this is winning
just knock off your list right now
policy genius.com and that way if you
buy it right now you could literally
just pull over on the road while you're
listening buy your life insurance
through policy genius calm and then your
family won't have to care if you die in
the car crash five minutes from now I
mean they'll still care I assume I hope
they love you but at least monetarily
they'll be taken care of so policy
genius calm that's the place so if like
Steve Ben and you or you were basically
disemboweled yesterday you wish you
would have used policy genius calm in
any case Steve ban and he has to come up
with a new philosophy of what he's gonna
do
so what Steve has done is he's always
used people to get where he wants to go
right he used Breitbart he used Palin he
used Hannity he used FoxNews he used
Roger Ailes he uses all these people and
then he turns on them when they become
inconvenient and he throws them under
the bus because that's who Steve is he
did it with the alt-right as well right
he said that he made himself a platform
for the alt-right and then when Milo you
innopolis ran into trouble then suddenly
Milo was dead to him right here he rode
Roy Morton told Roy Moore dropped like a
like a horse and then suddenly he said
Roy Moore is dead to me
right Ponyland well we'll back call
Nealon against paul ryan and then when
Nealon goes toxic then he's dead to me
right this is steve bannon's routine
okay so now see Bannon is out at the
white house and he still has but he has
to prop up his position of looking like
he's powerful so what can he do to look
powerful well he has to find again this
distinguishing point so he is now he's
made himself the face of this so-called
Trumpets philosophy but where can he
find somebody who reflects that Trump is
philosophy well he has a couple of
options one he could go to Karl Rove
not that he could start a super PAC he
could raise a lot of money he could stay
behind the scenes he could try to
manipulate but that's not steve's he
wants to be out front right steve is the
only media mogul in human history who
had his own radio show right I was a
personality before I ran hey Lee Weyer
hey Steve Bannon was nothing until he
was associated with Breitbart but he was
the guy who was doing Breitbart news
radio it just demonstrates what Steve's
sort of idea of himself is which is he
wants to be a public figure he wants his
face to be on things he likes the
president Ben
so he wants to be a public figure so he
can't do Karl Rove and just fun things
from behind the scenes and build a
movement which is what you would
actually do if he wanted to build
movement instead he has to do something
different and when he has to do is he
has to find candidates will allow him to
go on stage would be the biggest guy
there right he has to go find a place
where he is different than Mitch
McConnell and the quote-unquote
establishment and he has to try and
channel Tea Party anger against the
establishment into support for the ban
and philosophy movement right to the ban
in movements he's gonna try and turn the
Tea Party to the Bandon party that's
gonna be his plan and the person he
chooses to do this because Bannon is not
a particularly bright political operator
is Roy Moore he says I'm gonna make Roy
Moore in Alabama my man so first he
tries to support mo Brooks in Alabama
which is the correct move then when mo
Brooks loses he says I'm gonna support
Roy Moore over Luther strange in the
runoff despite all of row Moore's
toxicity I'm gonna stand in part because
of where I'm Moore's toxicity because
Roy Moore is the kind of guy who will
say anything he's much more a Trumpy
figure than the Luthor's range he'll say
anything that he wants to say he'll
stand up to anyone he's a tough rough
son of a right now that's the shtick and
so he's gonna support Roy Moore
especially because Mitch McConnell
supporting Luther strange and then Trump
comes down on Luther stranger side and
Bannon says well it doesn't matter I'm
more of a representative in some ways
convenient I'm more of a representative
of trumpism / man anism
than Trump is Trump is a figure but I'm
a philosopher
if Trump really were philosopher he'd
support Roy Moore but there's only one
problem
Roy Moore is a horrible candidate such a
horrible candidate that Roy Moore goes
on to lose goes on to lose for the first
time in 30 years a Republican seat in
Alabama because of allegations of child
molestation and steam is so deep down
this hole now he can't pull out as Steve
is so deep down this hole that he takes
Breitbart
a publication he always used as his
personal baton to wield against his
enemies he takes Breitbart and he uses
it as a baton to wield against the
alleged victims of malla station for Roy
Moore he has Alex Marlow a guy know well
and a guy with whom I was once close
friends he takes Alex and he and Alex
goes out and says openly that he
believes the accusers against Roy Moore
but then they deploy reporters down to
Alabama to try to discredit the accusers
against Roy Moore and get Roy Moore
elected senator supposedly an attempt to
defend Trump or something which makes no
sense since Trump was not even
supporting Roy Moore
that primary ok so and then Bannon to
make matters worse convince his Trump to
jump in last minute to support Roy more
humiliating the president humiliating
abandon and humiliating the Republican
Party as Roy Moore goes down in absolute
flames as morally he should have
considering the allegations against him
so all of that said now Bannon is in a
real pickle he's in a real pickle
because he's picked a bunch of
candidates they all lost and Mitch
McConnell is suddenly working hand in
glove with President Trump suddenly been
and has not only been edged out he's
been edged out by the establishment
there's suddenly Republican unity around
a Republican program and his philosophy
of I'll burn it all down and build a
giant statue of ban and in the aftermath
that's completely falling apart right
there's nothing he can do because Mitch
McConnell did not back Roy Moore in
Alabama Mitch McConnell the Senate
conservatives fund did not back Roy
Moore in Alabama the the National
Republican Senatorial Committee did not
involve itself in that race so Mitch
McConnell was not the guy who convinced
Trump to go all-in for incredibly
alleged child molester and then in the
Mitch McConnell passes tax reform I
think she got a major be the only big
win the only big legislative win of
trumps administration comes after Steve
ban and leaves and comes in direct
contravention to Steve bannon's own tax
reform plan which would have involved
raising taxes on wealthy people which
this bill did not do so bannon's on the
road so now what can Bannon do and it
gets worse a few weeks ago I hear a
rumor that Steve Bannon has been cut off
by the Mercer's the Mercer's were his
money fund and basically after Roy Moore
the Mercer said enough of this this con
man were done and they decide they're
not gonna fund any more Steve Bannon
projects that was at least the going
rumour in in sort of political circles
so Steve's desperate so what does Steve
do well Steve only has one ally left
it's not Trump the Trump isn't really
taking his phone calls the last time
Trump talked abandon was like early
December apparently it's no longer it's
no longer his allies at Fox News who
won't have him on after the war and more
thing righty's the famines basically
been absent since then it's not the
Mercer's cuz the Mercer's aren't
providing him cash anymore so he has
only one out I left the only ally he has
left are the people who built him up in
the first place and that is the members
of the mainstream media that's all he
has left is the members of the
mainstream media who have in who have a
concern and an interest in making Ben
and continue to appear a powerful figure
so they can foster conflict in
side the Republican Party as the longer
Bannon is out there lurking sniping at
Trump sniping at McConnell creating
chaos the better it is for the media the
better story it is the better narrative
and the worse it is for conservatives
and Republicans so Bannon has to go back
to the media right the thing he goes
finally back to his only Ally the people
he's been lying about about ripping
right the reality is that when when when
Bannon left the White House only one
thing was lost right only only one thing
declined when Bannon left the White
House and that was the phone bill to
Maggie Haberman at the New York Times
right and and the phone bill to Politico
and the phone bill to all the other
outlets that Steve Bannon was allegedly
leaking to right Steve Bannon loves
talking to the press which is why he was
quoted recently and his woman talked
about now he did an entire series of
interviews with Michael Wolfe who was
now written book called fire and fury
right the fire and the fury and this
book is coming out it's number one in
Amazon it's doing all sorts of business
because it's basically a bunch of gossip
from the White House the guy who brought
Michael Wolfe in was Steve Bannon si
Bannon was sitting there for hours a day
apparently talked with Michael wolf on
tape about his perception of the
universe right now Steve Bannon was the
most powerful figure who would be the
next president of the United States so
he goes back to his friends in the media
and his friends in the media he's gonna
leak to them and make it appear that
he's still a power player even though he
is not a power player even though he
never was a power player even though the
only perception of him as a power player
had been created out of whole cloth by
Steve Bannon and the mainstream media I
and the lock of Andrew Breitbart dying
and leaving him in charge of Breitbart
by the way he wasn't left in charge
Breitbart Larry Stoll of was Andrew
Breitbart to partner in crime and Larry
still have taken the reins at Breitbart
as well he should do now by firing Steve
Ann and he should never have hired
Steven and I urged him at the time not
to hire Steve ban but in any case he did
now he should move away from that as
fast as possible so he goes back to his
members of the mainstream media and he
leads to them just as he was fired from
the administration for leaking to the
American Prospect about how Trump didn't
know he was doing in North Korea and
what he dropped to Michael Wolff was a
bunch of crap about all his enemies in
administration hey that's that's all
this was it was just him riffing about
the administration and a bunch of people
in the media picked up on this Wolf's
book and they say well he must have
inside knowledge of corrupt activities
inside the Trump administration this is
what they jump on they're looking for an
excuse to Club Trump into submission
over Trump Russia collusion or over
criminal activity because let's face it
the members of
Media are still waiting for the day OS
Mackinac they're still waiting for the
god of the machine to come in or outside
the machine to come in and fix
everything they're still waiting for
Muller to come in from the skies like a
like or a like a vengeful Valkyrie and
behead president Trump and make Hillary
president so now Bandhan is out there
telling the press that Donald's from jr.
acted treasonous Lee
he was unpatriotic and it was bad bleep
right and that they should have called
the FBI now stand and the media said
well that means that he must have known
something bad was going on at that
meeting Steve Bannon didn't join the
campaign until August okay that meeting
took place in June June July August last
I checked June is before August Steve
Banta had no internal knowledge what
happened to that meeting I think the
meeting was bad myself by the way but
the idea that Steve Bannon has the goods
is just asinine and then he says that
Breitbart is not even a legit
publication which of course we already
knew I've I said that in March 2016
Wright was roundly excoriated by a lot
of people who are on Trump's side how
dare you say Breitbart isn't legit
publication has it it wasn't since
Bannon took it over right since Bannon
really began running the shop it had
turned into Benton's personal tool and
then he said that then he goes after
Kushner Johanna from Jared Kushner and
he said that his involvement with Russia
was greasy and it was all about and it
was all about the the Deutsche Bank
corruption and they're sitting on a
beach trying to stop a category-5 went
through some of this yesterday and then
Steve Bannon apparently says in the book
also that Ivanka is dumb as a brick so
he's just a brilliant guy he decides to
go back to the media and leak on
everybody and talk about how terrible
everybody is and all the rest right the
the the entirety of all of this amounts
to he goes to war with the guy who made
him prominent in the first place I think
he he goes to work I made a problem in
the first place
and finally Trump has had enough okay
this brings us to Donald Trump losing it
with with Bannen and doing the finest
thing any human being has ever done on
this planet and going off on Bannen and
in in truly epic fashion and in second
I'm going to tell you what Donald Trump
had to say and why Donald Trump is right
about all of it okay but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsor is over at
quit quit is the new electric toothbrush
it packs just the right amount of
vibrations into an ultra slim design
with guiding pulses to simplify better
brushing at a fraction of the cost of
bulkier designs i equip every morning
and every evening and not only that they
will send you the brush heads when you
sign up for their program they send you
the brush heads in the mail so you don't
have to worry about running to the store
or you forgot about changing your brush
head now getting canker sores because
you didn't replace it you're four months
overdue
that's what qyp makes easy it's great
for travel so when I had a different
electric toothbrush I wouldn't travel
with it because it's heavy and bulky you
have to bring the charger and the whole
deal clip is basically the size of a
normal toothbrush and yet it's electric
it's just fantastic it starts at 25
bucks and right now when you get when
you go to get quick comm slash Shapiro
you get your first refill pack free with
a quip electric toothbrush first refill
pack free get quick comm slash Shapiro
that's get quip comm slash apparel 75%
of us do not refresh our bristles every
three months let alone visit the dentist
every six quip makes it easy
go to get quip comm slash Shapiro GE tqu
IP comm slash Shapiro go ahead and check
that out
alright so finally president Trump loses
it on on Steve Bannon right he just he
absolutely loses it on Bannon and
releases one of the great epic burns in
the history of American presidential
politics it really is unprecedented for
the president to take a member of his
own cabinet basically and just dump I
mean the this this dump it's an epic
dump I mean it basically is the scene
from Back to the Future where Marty
McFly somehow maneuver is Biff into
driving his brand-new car into the back
of the manure truck and that's
essentially what happened here and so
Trump here will do Trump's statement in
just a second but you know what I'm
gonna make you wait I'm gonna make you
go over to to daily wire.com and
subscribe so we do that right now
no not yet you know what no you know
what we'll do one more okay fine so here
is the statement from President Trump I
won't i won't tease you like that
here's the statement from president
Trump here is you ready Steve Bannon
has nothing to do with me or my
presidency when he was fired he not only
lost his job he lost his mind
Steve was a staffer who worked for me
after I'd already won the nomination by
defeating 17 candidates often described
as the most talented field ever
assembled in the Republican Party now
that he is on his own Steve is learning
that winning isn't as easy as I make it
look Steve had very little to do with
our historic victory which was delivered
by the forgot who
women of this country its t-test you've
had everything to do with the loss of a
Senate seat in Alabama held for more
than 30 years by Republicans Steve
doesn't represent my base he's only in
it for himself
he pretends to be at war with the media
which he calls the opposition party yet
he spends his time at the White House
leaking false information to the media
to make himself seem far more important
than he was it's the only thing he does
well Steve was rarely in a one-on-one
meeting with me and only pretends to
have had influence to fool a few people
with no access and no clue whom he hoped
to write phony books we have many great
Republican members of Congress and
candidates who are very supportive of
the make America great again agenda like
me they love the United States of
America and are helping to finally take
our country back and build it up rather
than simply seeking to burn it all down
slow clap that builds into an impressive
round of applause for the President of
the United States this every word of
this is true Steve Danon is not
responsible for firm's victory he's not
responsible for Trump's agenda he is not
responsible for Trump's philosophy yes
he is not responsible for Trump's
accomplishments in the last two months
Trump has gotten more done in the last
two months without Steve ban in there
than he did in the entirety now Steve
bannon's tenure in the White House now
other members of the Trump team have
also sounded off about about Bannon it's
there at my former colleague at
Breitbart and my friend Larry O'Connor
and he had a good piece of the
Washington Times saying this is the
first time the conservative movement has
been united since the election cycle was
around Steve ban and getting his ass
kicked by Trump that's basically correct
no one likes Bannon the reason no one
likes mananitas Bannon is a bad man he's
a bad man who uses people and abuses
people he's a person who doesn't have
any thoroughgoing philosophy he does not
care about policy he does not believe in
a conservative approach to governance he
is not somebody who believes in anything
but Steve Bannon and watching Bannon
burned down and watching Trump recognize
the flaw in Bannon and and cleanse his
administration of a nefarious force that
was willing to make common causes enemy
was Bannon who was telling Trump
apparently to blame both sides in
charlotte's know it was Bannon who
originally formulated the travel ban
that ended up being struck down by the
courts because he was too stupid to
actually go to the lawyers and ask them
how to do it right Trump's
administration just got a lot better by
separating off from Steve and even
bright Bart knows that Breitbart is
running the stories straight today
right the commenters at Breitbart are
very anti Bannon as well they should be
because Bannon was undermining strumpet
undermining Trump's agenda when I was
anti Trump I was anti Trump because I
didn't feel that Trump was before the
conservative agenda when Trump has been
for the conservative agenda I have
cheered him when ban insured for Trump
it wasn't about the conservative agenda
it was about what does Trump do for
Bannen that's it I think the reader is
over at Breitbart are aware now of that
I think the reader is over a Breitbart
hour issue-oriented many of them I think
that they like Trump because they think
that they're gonna get out of Trump what
they want to get out of Trump I think a
lot I used to work there I believe that
a lot of the people who follow Breitbart
aren't doing so because they want to
follow Steve ban and down the rabbit
hole of his personal ambition and I
think that people are beginning to wake
up to this so there was widespread
celebration it's basically you know the
recut of a Return of the Jedi which I
just watched recently the recut which is
not as good as the original but in the
recut after the second Death Star is
blown up
spoiler alert there are a bunch of shots
of random people around the galaxy
celebrating right they just inserted
this for the release and it's like
people on Naboo celebrating ok that's
basically how it was around conservative
media yesterday when Steve Bannon was
torched by the president when he was set
on fire Minetta for actually works cuz
Bannon called himself Darth Vader in any
case Donald Jr went off on Bannen and
he's exactly right he says Steve had the
honor of working in the White House and
serving the country unfortunately he
squandered that privilege and turned
that opportunity into a nightmare of
backstabbing harassing leaking it lying
and undermining the president Steve is
not a strategist he's an opportunist
amen
hey Mitch McConnell who is the guy who
got Trump not only Justice Gorsuch but
also the tax cut I I love that the troll
the troll is strong in this one
I had tweeted out myself that Mitch
McConnell that this would be Mitch
McConnell's reaction so apparently team
Mitch basically picked up on it here is
what Mitch McConnell tweeted out in the
aftermath of people who can't see it as
a shot of Mitch McConnell just slowly
smiling and it's it's pretty it's pretty
glorious Sarah Huckabee Sanders like you
have to understand no one likes Steve
Bannon because he Bannon is a toxic
personality like I know many people who
work in the White House there was not a
note of disapproval
about anything that happened yesterday
Sara Huckabee Sanders here's what she
had to say about President Trump's
statement I mean all I can say about the
statement honestly it's so brutal that
rose it was for the first time Rosie
O'Donnell realized that Trump was going
easy on her after reading that statement
about city abandon I mean Trump
basically went full zoolander gasify ton
Bannon he basically took a tank of gas
and threw it all over Bannon and then
lit a match and just real men walk away
from explosions here's Sarah Huckabee
Sanders explaining they that much to
talk about here I'm in the statement
pretty much speaks for itself hiring him
I think the president's statement is
extremely clear what his position on mr.
bannon is I was pretty lengthy and
pretty detailed and there's not really
much to clarify or to add once again I
think the president's statement fully
addresses what his position and what his
relationship with mr. Bannon is okay so
this is exactly right and all of this is
well-deserved
this was coming to a man who thought
that he was bigger than the president
not only bigger than the president
bigger than the conservative movement
bigger than the tea party bigger than
Andrew Breitbart bigger than Sarah Palin
a man with outsized ambition buried by
his own ambition if you want to see
whether this is good for Trump all you
have to do is see how Democrats are
reacting to it so suddenly Bannon is
their hero right so Bannon had been
ripping Trump up and down and suggesting
that there was deep spread widespread
corruption inside the Trump campaign and
you can see the Democrats are seizing on
that as though Bannon has anything new
to say Bannon was not in the know Bannon
was not there until late in the campaign
okay Mueller is the one who's gonna know
whether something went on I don't know
whether something went on you don't know
whether something went on the media
don't know there's something went on and
guess what Steve Bannon doesn't know if
something went on either hey Steve
Bannon is not aware of something went on
either so you can see the Democrats
seizing on this and trying to and trying
to pretend that this is good evidence
that the Trump is gonna go away very
soon Julian Castro Democratic
Representative he says that that Bannon
definitely has evidence of money
laundering that's that's really the key
here I can't talk about what I heard in
the interview but I can tell you that my
impression after sitting through those
hours of that interview is that the
president should be concerned about
issues of money laundering of collusion
and obstruction of justice I say that
that's my impression not only from
hearing that witness but also many of
the other witnesses that have come
before the committee do this White House
should be nervous about what what has
been told of the committee and do you
believe while you as you said you can't
necessarily you know tell us exactly
what you heard in those hearings do you
believe that you heard evidence of
crimes committed by members of this
administration okay so yeah they're
jumping on the band and stuff in order
to try and discredit Trump which shows
you why Bannon had to be ousted and why
he had to be burned by Trump here it was
all bandhans own doing well we're going
to have to take a break here in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at tripping calm so
over at tripping calm you can spend less
time planning your next trip more time
relaxing with tripping comet is the
world's number one site for vacation
rentals trusted by millions of travelers
featured by the New York Times Travel
and Leisure Forbes and more with
tripping Commons what's great about this
onesearch lets you filter compare and
sort over ten million available
properties on sites like VRBO
TripAdvisor booking comm and more and
what's great about tripping comm is that
you are really working for Ava Kitts
vacation rentals so it's not as much
about finding a hotel as it is about
finding a place that you can rent it
actually has for example a kitchen right
looking for a cabin or a beachfront home
this is actually really important to me
personally so I use trippin comm because
when I vacation I actually can't stay in
a hotel for a long period of time
because I have to cook kosher food I
need a stove I need stove and I have
kids I need a washing machine too so the
only places that have that are usually
condos for rent or a cabin for rent with
tripping comm you can make all of this
happen right you can make sure that
you're getting the best deal on a New
Year's Eve cabin or winter beach
vacation you save an average an average
of 18 percent per night by booking your
vacation with trippin comm so don't
forget you want to save time and money
and you want to get the best available
property by the way it's much more fun
to stay in a condo than it is to stay in
a hotel room in my personal opinion is a
guy who stays in a lot of hotel rooms
it's a lot more fun to stay in a place
where you have some space to spread out
try it you won't want to go back once
you've actually worked with stripping
comm go to trippin comm slash Shapiro
today go to trippin comm slash appear oh
that's trippin comm slash Shapiro use
the slash up here oh so they know that
we sent you and it will allow you to
save again and
18% per night by booking your vacation
with our friends over at tripping calm
so in just a second I'm going to explain
the conservative fallout because what
you'll see is there's a split a little
bit in the conservative movement over
all of this but first we're gonna have
to say goodbye to you on Facebook and
YouTube so if you're watching right now
Facebook live or YouTube then what you
should do is you go out and over and
subscribe for $9.99 a month can get the
rest of this show live where else are
you gonna get great fantastic
inside information inside baseball
content like this the answer is no where
we make your life better pay us
okay that's basically the page so $9.99
a month and you get a subscription to
daily wire con that means you get the
rest of this show live Andrew Clavin
show live Michael Moses show live you
get my mailbag
but you are gonna be doing what day is
it it's Thursday right so we're gonna be
doing that on Friday we're doing that
tomorrow so you actually get to ask her
questions live to me and I will answer
them and make your life that much better
which is to say immeasurably so $9.99 a
month makes you gives you all that plus
if you get the annual subscription you
get all of those things plus you also
get this the very greatest in all
beverage vessels the leftist tiers hot
or cold beverage vessel
this thing's magnificent I mean look at
this watch I'm tired I'm worn down
not anymore gang
I just sipped from the leftist here's
how to call the beverage vessel you get
that for the annual subscription the
replenishing and life-affirming beverage
vessel the leftist year's hot or cold
tumbler
so you go check that out you get that
with the annual subscription you just
want to listen later YouTube please
subscribe we have lots of new videos
coming out all the time you can go to
SoundCloud iTunes any of the any of the
places that play podcast and check it
out we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
so the goal of the media is to keep
panning around so understand that that
capping ban and putting a elite taking
taking the gun and leaving the cannoli
is the best strategy for it for Trump
and for the conservative movement at
this point the leftist want to keep
banding around because they want to keep
fostering this internecine warfare if
you read the excerpts from Michael
Wolf's book fire and fury it's a lot of
inside gossip it's a lot of stuff about
how Trump's a crazy guy who likes to
stay up late and watch TV and he tweets
a lot okay if you follow his twitter
none of this is foreign information to
you like he tweets at all hours we
already know he likes KFC we know that
he is Petty and vengeful in many cases
like none of this is breaking news
write it welcome to the real world folks
a lot of it is just gossipy stuff that
makes people turned on right Melania
didn't actually want to be first lady
maybe that's true who cares and a lot of
it is Steve Mann and basically just
mentally masturbating about his own
power right I tweeted yesterday that
this book should have been called as
told by Steve Bannon because it just
reads like that it reads like bannon's
fever dream about what his role in the
movement is and who Trump is and calling
all of his enemies bad people and idiots
and morons and yet magically the
administration seems to be working
incredibly better since banned and left
and while he was there weird how that
works isn't it isn't it weird how
dysfunction seems to follow that guy in
any case then people are making a big
deal out of the the revelations in this
book the revelations are of no value to
me the reason they're of no value of me
is because they already they already
knew this like if you think that Trump
was not a dysfunctional character I
don't know what show you've been
listening to for the last couple of
years yeah I've always thought that
Trump had serious character issues now
the question is how do those manifest
themselves in policy in the last couple
of months that man has seldom manifested
themselves in some bad tweeting and some
silly statements in undercutting his own
popularity all that's bad I've discussed
all of that but in terms of policy
hadn't done much
okay so Trump changed his own sheets
because he's afraid that somebody's
gonna poison him or something right is
what the book says or that he eats KFC
because he's afraid that the White House
chef is gonna kill him hey let's say all
of that's true for the sake of argument
maybe it is maybe maybe he's like that
yeah JFK was allegedly doing LSD and
knocking on the interns right I mean
that the idea that any of this
necessarily translates to governance is
not from now is it great what I prefer
we had it a character of moral
uprightness and rectitude in the White
House of course
have I not been clear about this did I
stutter but let's be also clear about
something all of the revelations people
are finding so juicy in this book are
really not revelations at all we already
knew this it's just kind of a confirming
detail but the media is going nuts over
it because they want to paint the
picture of Trump as crazy person and the
country can't handle a crazy person when
in reality the stock market just crossed
25,000 and the economy is doing really
well and on foreign policy we're making
moves that are excellent for our for our
national prestige and power all that's
good so that that bifurcation may be
weird to people but unfortunately that's
the way that reality works sometimes joy
behar though he's trying to jump on all
the badness of our Trump needs to be
hospitalized he's just crazy is this
kind of a crazy game we're playing you
know he needs to be medicated in
hospitalized or he is going to just kill
all of us and you know my feeling is
that probably they're getting closer to
him in the Muller investigation and
that's what this is about a lot of it
it's like he'll blow the whole world up
so either his stupid songs don't have to
go to jail yeah that's clearly what's
happening right here right is that he
wants to blow up the whole world to his
sons don't go to jail yeah that's like
this is the the picture the left wants
to paint and ban and help them paint it
that's on Van and now there have been a
number of conservatives who have been
sort of hedging their bets in the Bandon
versus Trump flame war so Bannon himself
went silent yesterday he hosted
Breitbart news radio and he had nothing
to say he said Trump is a great man and
I support him in every way except for
you know routinely leaking on him and
ripping his children and tearing apart
members of his administration and
crapping all over his agenda and leaking
to the American Prospect at his North
Korean policy is stupid then suggesting
that he's a child and a except for
all of that I'm really on his side I've
been fantastic right that was Bannen
steak they're a couple takes on that one
is that Bannon knows he's in trouble and
the only thing he can do here is
basically grab Trump's leg and refuse to
let go right like my toddler what I'm
leaving the house I just grabbed that
leg and if I don't let go then maybe
daddy won't leave daddy left Steve
you're done right okay so there's that
there's also the possibility that Steve
shut up because Trump actually had his
lawyers draft up and sent a letter
threatening with c.width violation
violations of his non-disclosure
agreement so Steve had apparently a
pretty strong non-disclosure agreement
with the
campaign now the non-disclosure with
President Trump in good hold because for
Public Policy reasons when you leaked
about the president unless it's
classified material no judge is gonna
uphold that their First Amendment
concerns that come into play when you're
when you're giving out information about
a public official like the president but
when it comes to the when it comes to
private information on the campaign
trail and Steve very well could've
violated the NDA and there is a
significant possibility that the Trump
could actually have a pretty strong case
for violating the NDA in all of these
leaks so that's a problem for Steve so
maybe that's why Steve shut up
maybe I mean we don't know it said
that's a possibility it is also being
awesome possible as I say I think that
the more likely scenarios that Steve is
is just the the firestorm yesterday was
so intense it was like the scene at the
end of the last Jedi with the eighty
eighties and look like it was it was it
was that yesterday except Steve was not
a hologram and Steve is not a Jedi so
that really did not go well for him
yesterday he ended up looking like uncle
uncle Owen and aunt Beru in Star Wars
Episode four by the end of yesterday so
a lot of Star Wars reference this today
in any case he he so he doesn't say
anything about it a lot of his allies
and he only has a couple of allies in
the media Steve these are people he's
cultivated for year so he called to
vetted Sean Hannity he calls a baton
Laura Ingraham he cultivated Ann Coulter
he has a habit of cultivating people and
then they were still useful to him so he
hadn't thrown them over yet Sean is torn
because Sean had basically painted
Bannon as the ideological sort of avatar
of the conservative wing of the White
House I don't know how Sean I honest to
god I don't know how Sean holds that
view given the fact that the White House
has gotten more conservative not less
since banned and left I I've never
understood how Sean has been able to
rectify his view of Bannen desk policy
with conservatism right I grew up
listening to Sean I grew up watching
Sean I owned his books I'm friendly with
Sean I think Sean's a really good guy
but I've never understood how Sean was
able to so easily move into
nationalist populist nonsense when he
spends his entire career advocating
conservatism
so you'll see Sean try to play the
middle road here he doesn't he feels bad
about just dumping on Bandhan but he
also knows that Trump is not gonna stand
for him not dumping on banning so here
is his way so he tries to blame it on
the media this is always the easy out
right it's the media's fault except from
one problem Bannon wasn't misquoted so
the easy out here would have been Bannon
saying well I was misquoted by Michael
Wolfe it was all false only one problem
Bannon
Michael Wolff into the White House sat
with him and taped with him for hours
for hours and wolf has the tapes so here
is Sean desperately trying to avoid
condemning Bannon
while also desperately attempting to
avoid offending Trump immediately loves
love steve madden for the moment they
love when republicans or conservatives
are fighting and create a circular
firing squad in real life they hate
Bannon and they hate Trump and but
they'll you know right now they'll be
supportive of Steve Bannon if he think
he's certain that dancing there call us
they love these intramural fights they
love palace intrigue
they love to analyze who's up who's down
it's another example the media's
priorities are so screwed up
when do they ever talk about you when do
they ever talk about okay so as I've
said I agree with Shawn then the media
loves this internation warfare but the
solution to the internecine warfare is
to go after the guy who's the leaker
right we kept hearing that leakers were
bad there is all this deep state stuff
you know who was the head of the deep
state leaking in favor of his own
interests the head of the band in deep
state was Steve bandana C Bannon was the
sieve man in deep state and Shawn's
trying to avoid that implication but
that is the reality the media doesn't
have this material unless Steve and his
self aggrandizing arrogance believes
that he can leak all this material to
the press and get away with it Laura
Ingraham did the same thing last night
slamming Trump and ban and saying well
why do you guys have to fight why do
mommy and daddy have to fight but fellas
it doesn't really make sense for a
high-profile advisor and its former boss
to publicly attack each other when the
stakes are this high how does that make
any sense
okay well Laura let's start with
something hold on hold on one second
hold on one second
Steve Bannon attacked before Trump did
okay that all of trumps fans are always
saying that he only hits back in this
case he did only hit back it was not
Trump hitting Bannen it was Steve ban
and hitting Trump doing it publicly
hitting his kids suggesting there was
actual crime committed inside the Trump
campaign which would lead to the
impeachment of the president according
to Michael Wolf's book he was leaking to
Michael Wolfe that he thought there was
a one-third chance of impeachment and
one-third chance of resignation and a
one-third chance Trump finishes his term
and he wanted to run for presidents
replace Trump hey if you are a fan of
Trump if you want Trump to succeed how
in the world are you still holding out
for Steve ban and after that how in the
world are you holding out for ban it in
what world have I become more
from then a lot of the Trump whites who
are now trying to defend Steve Bannon
okay first of all there aren't very many
of them and all of the ones who are
think of themselves personal friends
abandon but for Laura to draw a moral
equivalence between Trump and man and
this fight is just ridiculous okay this
is this Dom ban and pure and simple
Trump is right to snack him and Trump
did the right thing by taking him down
at least a thousand pegs here and
leaving him a smoldering husk of
humanity listen am I happy that he did
this on a personal level yes I am he
said think Steve Bannon is a bad man I'm
not gonna hide it okay I think Steve is
a bad man who did bad things sided with
bad people made good people's lives
miserable
use those bad people to target his
opponents I think Steve is a very bad
influence on the President of the United
States I think the president is much
better off that he's no longer
associated with this piece of crap but
with all of that said I would believe
that whether or not I knew Steve Bannon
Steve has not been of net benefit to
this presidency and I dare anyone to
name me away one way in which Steve
Bannon has been of net benefit to the
President of the United States do you
really believe that Trump wouldn't want
a fan and head and joined the campaign
do you really think that cuz you'll have
to explain to me how that works
considering the ban and never did
anything with the campaign in any case I
want to get to some things I like and
some things that I hate but that's
that's a lot of man and for one day and
hopefully that will be one of the last
times we have to mention Steve Danon
on air good riddance to bad rubbish
already time for some things I like and
some things I hate and then we'll do a
little bit of Bible talk in which I will
mention Steve BAM and so things I like
let's begin there
so Adam driver has become maybe I just
didn't know about him he's a really good
actor
like Adam Trevor's a very good actor
he's the only thing that makes a last
Jedi worth watching I think is Adam
drivers performance as kylo Ren kylo
could have been a whiny annoying
character and instead he really makes
him quite interesting I think that that
Adam friend if you watch Adam driver in
anything the guy can do anything there's
a movie called Logan lucky Steven
Soderbergh film and with Channing Tatum
who also is a surprisingly good actor
and Daniel Craig who is also a
surprisingly good actor and basically
it's about a heist where they rob the
coca-cola 600 is that what it is
the coca ho 500 I can't remember the
name of the actual NASCAR race the day
that they rock in any case
yeah it's Daniel Craig really playing
against type like really playing against
type in a major way but the one who
steals the shows drivers
driver plays this this Iraq war vet
who's lost his arm and has an almost
uncontainable temper that he hides
behind this implacable exterior he's
terrific and here's a little bit of the
preview of Logan lucky which is
definitely worth the rental it's a fun
movie it's just it's a fun popcorn movie
with some really good with it really is
not an action movie per se it's much
more just a heist movie and it's a it's
a top-ten heist movie I'd say maybe a
top-five heist movie it's really that
good
[Music]
Jim I'm just gonna say it I gotta let
you go
you were just fired Oz let go for
liability reasons involved in insurance
the one-armed bartender so no respect
Charlotte Motor Speedway
okay the preview itself is it the movie
itself is really good Adam driver is a
revelation I've seen him in three or
four different films now and he just he
inhabits characters in a way that really
there are very few actors who inhabit
character like I actually think Channing
Tatum does in this movie - I think
Channing Tatum is actually quite good as
well
but Adam driver I can't speak highly
enough about his ability to perform
really it's pretty incredible he as an
actor like Christian Bale when you're
watching Christian Bale movie you don't
actually see Christian Bale you just see
the character the Christian Bale is
playing which is the opposite of movie
stars like Jack Nicholson where no
matter what part he's playing he's Jack
Nicholson playing the part I think even
Meryl Streep has that problem when you
watch had him drive you're like wait is
that Adam driver even though he's not
wearing any makeup or prosthetics or
anything you go oh yeah that is Adam
driver like that's kylo Ren but he's a
completely different character really
really good in this film I check it out
it's a fun movie to watch Hilary Swank
has kind of a fun bit part and Daniel
Craig is also a lot of fun in the movie
okay some a couple of things that I hate
so there is a there's a phenomenon that
is now taking place that I don't really
know how to describe it is the
phenomenon where people get so used to
the government taking care of them they
get so used to a regime of regulation
that they forget how to be normal human
beings this is a criticism that a lot of
people on the right have had for a long
time is that every time the government
passed a law it makes you dependent on
that law every time the government does
something where they where they
essentially tell you what to do and what
you can't do when they tell you you
can't do something then they fill it in
with government regulation then you
start to think you can't do it yourself
and this is what happened with welfare
people started being able to receive a
check for being a single mother and so
people said well maybe I don't need to
marry a guy right incentives change and
government can enervate you government
can turn you into a mewling droop of
humanity government can turn you into a
dependent of the state the most obvious
example is in the last couple of days so
in Oregon there was a law I used to work
for a company that was based in Southern
Oregon I recall this there's a law in
Oregon that you are not allowed to pump
your own gas right you really this was a
law that you had have an attendant pump
your gas like it's 1953 and you're
pulling into the drivin they'd have
somebody come over to your car and pump
your gas and the first time it happens
you're like oh this is kind of nice and
the second time you just happens you're
like this would be a lot quicker if I
could just hop out of my car and put my
own gas we who have been growing up in
regular America where you pump your own
gas since like the 1920s we've been
thinking well what's up with this luck
so but here's the funny part so there's
a House bill 2482 it took effect on
Monday and retailers in counties with a
population of less than 40,000 are now
allowed to have self-service gas pumps
drivers in those 15 counties can now
pump their go own gas any time of day
well in those other three rural counties
they can do so after business hours
between 6 p.m. and 6 a.m. it was a
make-work program and so it's in the
idea was there a bunch of unhireable is
except for pumping gas and so we will
actually make a law preventing you from
pumping your own gas but the result was
thousands of people who don't know how
to pump their own gas and think they're
gonna like themselves on fire so these
are some of the facebook posts from
these people are you ready for this
because it truly is pretty incredible
quote I don't even know how to pump gas
and I'm 62 native Oregonian I say no
thanks I don't like to smell like
gasoline ok I pump my own gas like once
a week
I don't smell like gasoline after doing
it I don't know what you're talking
about and another woman writes know
disabled seniors people with young
children in the car need help not to
mention getting out of your car with
transients around and not feeling safe
this is a very bad idea gir ok I promise
you do a lot of disabled senior people
with young children and old people and
transients in California like we're big
on the transients no one gets attacked
while pumping their gas another person
writes I've lived in the state all my
life and I refuse to pump my own gas
this is a service only qualified people
should perform qualified people you have
to have a state license to pump gas I
will literally park at the pump and wait
until someone pumps my gas
ok screw you people who think this and
screw the government for having lead
people to believe that are incapable of
pumping their own gas you wonder why we
have a population that seems so
incapable
performing basic daily functions maybe
it's because the government tells them
they can't when you have people your
entire life telling you you can't do
things this is why I hate so much of the
talk about white privilege the
implication being if you're not white
you can't succeed you can work hard
succeed it basically when people say
that you are a victim or you're
incompetent there are very few
professions where you should need a
license hey to pump gas is not one of
those professions it's so ridiculous but
again it shows that human nature is the
one you've been told for years and years
and years you can't do something you
actually think you're not qualified to
do something it's there are a lot of
people in blue state to feel this way
about guns I've never seen a gun I've
never held a gun guns are so scary I
could never fire a gun no you can i
promise like go to a gun range somebody
else eat you ain't that hard okay other
things that I hate and speaking of the
the ridiculous left a food safety expert
has now warned that there is a raw water
friend okay there's a raw water there's
a real thing okay there's a New York
Times trend piece on Silicon Valley's
recent obsession with raw water
according to The Times demand for
unfiltered water is skyrocketing as tech
industry insiders develop a taste for
water that has not been treated to
prevent the spread of bacteria or other
contaminants in San Francisco unfiltered
untreated unsterilized spring water is
selling for as much as sixty one dollars
for a 2.5 gallon jug their startups
dedicated to untreated water there are a
bunch of people who say that raw water
is perfect for people who are extreme
about health ok the you know how stupid
you have to be to believe this like not
treating water makes people sick why do
you think people die of dysentery in
third-world countries why do you think
they tell you to bring bottled water
when you go to Mexico City like the
whole point here is that you have
untreated water you could die virtually
every contaminant is is neutralized by
treatment of water why do you think it's
imperative that we actually give
equipment to people in third-world
countries they can boil water and turn
it into drinkable people in the West are
so stupid we're so dumb that we become
so prosperous that we now think they're
going back to primitive ways of living
that kills people are more healthy the
same when people say organic you know
organic will heal you this is about pot
you know pots organic how can it hurt
you poison poison ivy is organic too I
wouldn't use it as skin cream I'm not
saying the pot is poison ivy but I am
saying this argument that organics are
naturally healthier is just ridiculous
this isn't
cancer is organic what stupidity okay
final thing that I hate well actually
sorry two more things that I hate
because cuz I run the show okay here is
the first Keith Ellison Democrat from
Minnesota he was nearly the head of the
Democratic National Committee he tweeted
this out yesterday Keith Ellison was
associated with Louis Farrakhan
keith Ellison is a radical anti-semite
here's what he tweeted at Moon Palace
books and I just found the book that
strikes fear in the heart of Donald
Trump and it's him holding up a book
called an Tifa the anti-fascist handbook
and Tifa is basically a domestic terror
group okay aunt Eva there's tape of
Stephen Crowder's assistant not gay
Jared being offered actual weaponry at
one of my lectures by members of an Tifa
and Tifa break things and Tifa commit
acts of violence and Tifa is a the
reason that they call themselves nt but
they say they are anti-fascist but then
they say by any means necessary meaning
violent means the one of the leading
Congress people in the Democratic caucus
is now calling for support for a violent
leftist group and then you wonder why we
think why there's been a reactionary
move to trump this is how you got Trump
getting the final thing that I hate so
there the president Trump announced on
what was it Monday I've completely lost
track of all time I think it's Tuesday
actually I've lost track of time because
every news cycle is now one and a half
seconds long by the end of the show I
see my own would missed two news cycles
the on Tuesday Trump tweeted out that
who's gonna have the fake dishonest
media news award sees on Monday which I
look forward to at 5:00 p.m. on Monday
as I say I hope that he takes over all
through broadcast networks to do it and
members of the media don't understand
what's happening so they've been
releasing ads trying to troll Trump so
here is the one from Stephen Colbert and
it's a picture of Stephen Colbert
looking like he's in good night and good
luck
with a with a series of quote from Sean
Hannity and various various other people
saying how terrible he is and I quote
from Trump himself and and it's a
nomination poster right it's like a
nomination poster for the Oscars it says
in all categories including outstanding
achievement in parenting George Soros is
talking points best sound mixing best
checks mixing lease break party the Eric
trump memorial award for disappointment
fakest dishonesty crosses business
dishonest this corruption smallest
button okay sounds a little funny
I'll admit that it's that it's
pretty funny I will also suggest that
one of the problems here is that Stephen
Colbert actually does disseminate a
bunch of left-wing talking points and if
you want to make the case that you're
not a left-wing talking points
organization the way you do that is not
by trolling Trump about his fake news
stuff by saying we are fake news right
the only people I understand you know
Colbert doesn't portray himself as an
objective news source he prefers himself
as a comedian but when he covers news
he's not objective he was not the only
one doing this routine like they revel
in this right then you wonder why Trump
could run against Stephen Colbert and
win the reason you ran against Stephen
Colbert and won is because Stephen
Colbert is running against Trump they're
all running against Rahm but it's not
just Colbert it's also Samantha Samantha
bee and Trevor Noah here's a here's
Samantha bee so Samantha bee I tweeted
out her own ad it said for your
consideration Samantha bee for shrillest
reporting which I mean I would vote if
you're up for that category I would
certainly vote for that and and it's a
bunch of comments from YouTube commenter
she says
nice try Colbert and Daily Show but
we're sweeping the dishonest ease this
year yes Donald Trump having a female
host next time hahahaha cuz you know
like sexism she's not even funny like
that one's not even funny okay Colbert's
at least funny but but Samantha bee is
just comedy death I mean she's a bola of
comedy and then there's Trevor Noah
who's also in an open competition for
for this by the way I should mention and
before word gets out that the Daily Show
did invite me on with with Trevor Noah
I said that I will what I'm saying is
that I will do it but only if they
broadcast it live I'm not gonna do it
so it's live to tape and get kind of
part the way that Jonah Goldberg was on
The Daily Show this is always my my
insistence when I do a show like that
anyway daily Trevor Noah
put this up on as well most dishonest
and corrupt media awards of the Year
consideration and then it's a bunch of
quotes one from Breitbart news one from
Fox & Friends
I'm just disappointed even put one for
me so here's one for Trevor Noah for me
Trevor Noah is in a running gun battle
for least funny human being with
Samantha bee plus he's a political hack
on behalf of left has no clue about how
American politics actually work how's
that might be a little long for the
blurb but there it is in any case if
these people want to push from to
greater heights please continue to do
this okay final word we'll do a little
bit of Bible talk to a but this will be
a very very quick Bible talk so here it
is this is from Milan
Alif okay so in English that would be
first Kings to two to six okay and and
basically what it says is it's the story
of what David says to Solomon right as
Solomon is is about to take over today
was about to die and he instructs
Solomon to basically kill yo of the son
of zeruiah okay Zulu yeah okay so a job
Joey it's spelled Jo a B he was one of
his commanders and he broke a ceasefire
that David basically had with his son
Absalom Absalom and Joab had killed
Abner the son of ner and so David says
listen I couldn't do anything while I'm
alive so I made a promise I wouldn't
touch him but once I'm dead you can go
after this guy the reason he said that
is because job was acting on his own
orders he was basically off on his own
representing David ISM without David and
it didn't go well for him yeah maybe
maybe Steve should have read first Kings
because there were some lessons in there
about how the King actually treats you
when you when you disobey his wishes his
anger may sleep but not for not for long
alrighty we will be back here tomorrow
with all the latest news plus the
mailbags if you're gonna subscribe now
is the day to do it I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex Zingara audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jael O'Hara the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
publishing 2017